le lancement est réussi la sonde est en
route et son objectif est clair
s'écraser sur un astéroïde se trouve à
11 millions de kilomètres de la terre en
espérant que l'impact va le faire dévier
de sa course c'est le tout premier pas
vers la mise en place de systèmes de
défense planétaire
c'est la méga collision entre la comète
shoemaker levy et jupiter en 1994 qui a
ouvert les yeux des astronomes sur
l'importance de surveiller de près d
estoril qui circulent en périphérie de
la terre depuis 20 ans on en a détecté
près de 30000 de différentes tailles
construit maintenant à partir du sol
depuis ce temps le ya plusieurs projets
qui ont été lancés pour essayer de
répertorier zestoa on a fait beaucoup de
scénarios pour essayer de
se protéger de ça on n'a jamais rien
tester grandeur nature la mission d'arc
est relativement simple de côté un
boulet de 750 kg qui se déplace à 24
milles kilomètres à l'heure de l'autre
sa cible dix morts fausse une minuscule
une qui orbitent l'astéroïde himos 20
septembre 2022 le boulet va percuter sa
cible dans l'espoir de modifier très
légèrement sa course autour de dix 10
most un micro satellite de la nasa des
télescopes terrestres et en 2024 une
sonde européenne vont ensuite mesurer
précisément les faits de cette collision
sur la vitesse et leur [ __ ] de dix morts
fausse le choix de l'astéroïde dépôt
anodin son agresseur un astéroïde tout
seul ça a été très difficile de voir les
impacts à long terme ça m'a pris des
dizaines d'années les experts savent
qu'une modification même extrêmement
faible de la trajectoire d'un astéroïde
peu sur de très longues distances et
fumait énormément sa destination finale
acs persil pour éviter dans le futur une
hypothèse de ces collisions entre gros
astéroïde et la terre un événement
improbable à moyen terme mais
théoriquement possible le risque est
faible effectivement mais il pourrait
avoir des objets qu'on n'a pas trouvé
encore on s'en doute et si jamais il ya
on se rend compte qu'un risque ben
l'important ça va être de découvrir le
plus tôt possible mais aussi d'avoir des
stratégies efficaces
pour ce pour se défendre contre ça on
évalue qu'il ya plus deux millions des
stéroïdes qui circulent dans les deux
principales ceintures du système solaire
à partir de 140 mètres de diamètre et
selon l'endroit où ils s'écrasent ils
peuvent causer d'énormes dommages ici
norma grondin radio canada montréal